[Music]
don't we all feel a little awkward
venturing out after lockdown amidst the
covert 19 pandemic
deciding how close to get to someone or
how far to stay away
holding back a handshake or hug one
wrong move can be a question of life or
death
the fears are real and their
communicated subconsciously
through body language
considering how highly social humans are
how's all this affecting us
well the coronavirus has robbed us of
our most meaningful ways to connect with
each other
it's a little sad it can be stressful
too having to take
so much into consideration every time
you leave the perceived safety of your
own four walls
the coronavirus has turned the world
upside down
how has it affected us since the
lockdown in march
researchers from the university of basel
have been using cameras to document how
we adapt to daily life
how we behave and how we act and move
during the pandemic
with minor i must constantly decide with
my body where to stand
and these are micro decisions the bodily
movements
should i sit here or five centimeters
further away
these are the things that we're
recording
since the pandemic began our body
language has gained new meaning
everyday behavior is suddenly risky must
be renegotiated
or even dropped a lot of non-verbal
communication is going on between us
all the time
here is a good example of how they are
placing themselves naturally
in a way in which they can also keep
their distance
and these are micro decisions that
people make constantly
we're studying the activity of people
distancing themselves
how they really do it moment by moment
and one second at a time
a few days later the experts analyze
their findings at the university of
basel
they discuss and try to interpret every
dialogue every action
and every tiny bodily movement
one scene at a time image by image
in slow motion the findings from the 100
hours of video material should one day
help to better understand
humans as social beings the coronavirus
pandemic is almost a stroke of luck for
this unique research
project
we've only had two waves now what's
really going to happen will there be a
third or a fourth wave
are there constants are there routines
that will remain in the long run
that's what's interesting about human
interactions interaction interscientists
they've already discovered one thing in
basel
we constantly adapt our interactions to
a given risk situation
and we do it quickly that's a finding
that could also
benefit coronavirus strategies
understanding how people really tick
can help devise rules and measures that
people will actually follow
and let's talk more in depth with
lorenzo mondatta whom you saw in that
report
has covert 19 fundamentally changed the
way humans interact with each other
yes of course uh it seems to have
changed
quite a big deal of things now in order
to understand these changes i think we
have to
to think about social interaction as uh
even though it might seem a bit chaotic
sometimes
as having its own organization its own
order
and what kovi does as as provoked
is the arrival of a lot of external
norms external measures
for prevention for health safety for
risk
and one of the the motors of the change
but also the problematicity of this
change
is that sometimes these measures my
intrude with an external normativity
in the endogenous organic order of
social interaction
and uh this is uh one fascinating
uh things that we are looking at at the
project uh
i'm i'm living in basel what about
cultural differences
as an australian the germans would get
way too close to me often invading my
personal space
but i'm actually enjoying having all
this space myself now because of the
pandemic
yeah cultural variation is uh is a big
is a big things and for sure uh uh on
on certain details it will make things
easy for
certain kinds of groups rather than
others if we take the the example of
greetings that we have studied in uh
in in my project for sure greetings are
hugely variable
uh but if you look at a the structural
functional aspects of greetings
you will see that each culture has the
same problems to solve with
greetings showing reciprocity showing
recognition
and identification organizing the entry
in
interaction in a coordinated way so
those are the kind of uh
basic principles uh that uh greetings
in a way make uh make possible
and the way in which the format in which
they make
this this is made possible might be
subject of huge variation
and so if you if you uh use rather in
your culture
haptic formats so formats where you
touch a lot
which means you interact in close
distance
you might have more difficulties than in
a culture where
uh haptic formats are not so important
at the end of the day it's the
connection we're all looking for
how severe is the impact of social
distancing on human connection
yeah in the social sciences we are
pretty critical of the notion of social
distancing
because what we are witnessing with
kovid is a physical distancing
which is not always and not
automatically
social distancing it has of course a
social aspect it has a cultural
uh aspect but we have to think about the
fact that uh
distance is variable in social life
there are activities that are naturally
distant
other uh which need proximity and the
problem
with kovid is that we have these
measures imposing us
at two meters uh of of distance
which are perfectly implementable for
certain activities
much less for others and the decision
how to implement these measures
is a decision that people must take
locally
and this generates interesting but also
difficult
uh normative dilemmas uh that people are
confronted with
at some say so this is all going to be
over i hope
will there be long-term effects will
some of this be
here to stay
well of course it's difficult to say
there are
responses going in two different
directions
one is that kovid has been a revelatory
experience
for us as scientists but also as a
citizen
about what is fundamental in sociality
that we want to keep so we want to come
back
to a normal sociality and in a way those
values
were invisible before and covid has made
us
uh uh conscious about them but there are
also other things that have emerged
during covet kobit has been a natural
laboratory
for experimenting alternative forms of
social life
and some of the most creative will for
sure
stay dorenza mandata thank you very much
thank you to you time to answer more of
your questions now
over to our science correspondent derek
williams
how would the pandemic end only when the
entire world is vaccinated
when it comes to predicting the future
really your guess
is as good as mine but if i did have to
hazard one i'd say
there are a couple of scenarios to
choose from
the first and least likely in my opinion
is that will somehow manage to begin
coordinating efforts on a hitherto
unheard of scale to stymie
new outbreaks before they can spin out
of control
like they have already in country after
country any return to anything like a
pre-pandemic
normal at least on a global scale
will require speeding up and extending
vaccine drives in every corner of the
planet now
and not later and of course the virus
would have to play along by by not
mutating too quickly or or dramatically
so so an imaginable scenario but
one that a lot of epidemiologists think
isn't going to happen
more likely they say is that vaccines
won't stop covet 19 transmission
completely but they will
slow it in many places enough to manage
the virus
like we manage other diseases just think
um hiv aids or or measles
in that scenario soros cov2 would become
endemic and and possibly seasonal like
the flu
and would have to be held in check by
active measures like
like regular vaccine updates and as yet
undeveloped medications people
would continue to be infected by it and
and continue to die from it
but but over time as large fractions of
populations acquire
some degree of immunity for at least a
while
through infection or vaccines
a lot of experts think the disease could
grow
less deadly at least at the societal
scale
so instead of thinking about when the
pandemic will end
to me it now makes more sense to
formulate this question
as when will we get back to something
approaching pre-pandemic normalcy
and i think that could happen by the end
of the summer in some places like here
in europe um
in many others barring new developments
i expect it to take several years
that's my guess
[Music]
finally the games get underway in tokyo
in a couple months and organizers have
been trying out
one of the newest additions
skateboarding the athletes met
at ariako urban sports park to show off
their tricks
no spectators strict hygiene measures
though to keep
covert at bay concerns about hosting the
big event continued to grow
350 000 people signed a petition
the president of the olympic committee
officially acknowledged the petition and
says
the committee takes any concerns
seriously it's unclear though
if there'll be any changes to the games
thanks for watching and stay safe i'll
see you again very soon here on dw
bye
you